would billy won an award
participation
big wolf
i'm guessing something
let me eat the sharpest pencil in the
box but he's the sweetest kid i know
well sheldon is the sharpest pencil
sometimes i just like to shove his head
in that box
where's the trash
everywhere
but the basket's under the sink
you know your fuss is leaking yeah
so a place has fallen apart yeah
i'll come over another time to take care
of it you know you don't have to do that
one more
i should get going
well thanks again
want to buy a house
hey where you been yes
brendo was in car trouble just giving
her a hand that's nice i'm sure it's
hard being by herself yeah that whole
house is in need of repair i hope you
offered to help her out i did yeah she
said no well that's just her being proud
of course she wants your help
yeah you i'll get some time i'll pop one
good
and when you go hitch up your pants
there's a lot going on when you squat
all right
almost there
[Music]
hand me a screwdriver
don't stick this in an outlet it really
tingles
we had an incident yeah
you know what
why don't you fix it really really yeah
you see a little screw there just go
ahead and tighten her up
like this yeah
what now
uh run outside and turn the water back
on here i'm not allowed to run with this
we've had a lot of incidents
who knew you were so handy yeah there's
just things guys need to be good at what
else you good at
i should go
pretty lady
are you drinking already no
can't a guy give his wife a compliment
do i have to smell your breath how about
a kiss instead what is with you well i
don't know
kids aren't home
now i'm doing laundry laundry can wait
so can your thing
i like to think of it as our thing but
if you only have time for my thing
that's fine too you're being weird
weird sexy no
hit in the bedroom no
this chick
that toilet won't stop running
you try jiggling the handle i jiggled it
wiggled it damn near had a baby with it
now let me take a look i was fixing to
put some dinner on if you care to join
me
that won't put you out it's just frozen
lasagna but i'm going oven instead of
microwave cause you're company
what are you doing
what do you mean
you know what i mean
i was just trying to thank you
and you're the one who offered to come
over here and fix things i was being
nice may be a little too nice
there is no pleasing you i don't need
this here i can get fighting at my house
yeah maybe you should go back to your
house
mom can you help with my homework
they're in a sec
you leave it
are you going to fix the toilet no but i
guess i'm not leaving thank you lasagna
small piece mary's making tacos okay
trying to outsmart my own something like
that
you want to talk about it
no
tell me about your fun bachelor life
well as of last week i officially tasted
every campbell's soup please come on tom
i'm trying to live vicariously here
it's got to be something good that's
sick i go hunting and fishing whenever i
feel like it now getting somewhere spend
my money on whatever i want
what's the last thing you got foreman
fight on pay-per-view
i eat a bucket of chicken and watched it
in my underwear you lucky bastard
what about women
honestly
it's
tough to meet people at this age oh come
on chairman feeling like you
sadly this is the best night out i've
had in a long time
yeah me too
but if you know anybody
send them my way
yeah think about it
do you ever eat chicken in your
underwear
what do you think
yes yes
[Music]
do
you